this week is pretty major from the point
of view that not just putting in traffic
signals it's also replacing and
upgrading to a pipe storm water pipes
and water main so it's a pretty major
piece of work
we suggest commuters to look at
alternative reach to avoid the
intersection because more traffic that
user sends pics from the more delays
will be some of those alternatives are
for people living on the west side of
Frankie hora the fun side flex and
Counting road link on that and that
provides a direct connection into the
western side of regular for the Eastern
North is possibly using grandeur it
would end road as a route that will
avoid telstra parade so the other two
main routes that people should consider
people have to use the intersection then
we'd suggest their boards to pick climb
and peak time sighs at school start and
finish time and also strong about four
o'clock onwards in the evenings that
gets pretty congested so it's just
avoiding those times if you can